[Music]
we've lots to cover this morning we've
also got some really really great
stories from customers who are going to
join us up on stage so I'm going to
speak very quickly not just because I'm
Irish but because I want to get off the
stage as fast as I can and welcome as
more my colleagues and some of those
great customers up to share their
experiences with you so um a little bit
about myself and just give you a little
kind of personal journey I'm 11 years in
Google I spent two years running the
publisher side in Europe then I moved
across after double-click acquisition
and ran double-click for six years in
Europe and I've been in cloud for about
three and a half years at this stage and
I was really attracted to um you know
the transformation that was taking place
in people moving from an on-premise
world into a cloud world and what that
could mean for helping companies with
their own digital transformation what I
was particularly interested coming out
of the ad tech world about what cloud
computing could do and to really help
people with our marketing and how they
could interact with their own customers
so I saw it as compelling a
transformation story as the consumer
shift in Mobile which we all saw are the
shift of programmatic advertising so if
you think of those two big shifts and
another really really large shift that
we're seeing and I love this quote from
Gartner is this transformation and how
many marketers see that they will be
competing mostly are completely on the
basis of customer experience in two
years time the quotes from 2017 that
means that it should actually be
happening now it's just a quick question
to the audience do you do the marketers
who are in the room are you now most
they are completely competing on the
basis of customer experience are not
quite yet so yes okay that's pretty
interesting and I think one of the
reasons why like nothing's really
changed in marketing marketers are still
looking to acquire
retain and grow customers and they want
to put the customer in the center and
focus on customer engagement and really
want to focus on what we call like
creating delightful customer experiences
and that's going to help you to
you know predict who how much people
will spend in the future predict is your
customer is you likely to spend again
how do we find others like her at scale
etc so you've got all of these touch
points from your customers all of this
fantastic data you're collecting but a
lot of that data is sitting in either
technological silos or in organizational
silos in your organization and so that
makes it very hard to get a a you know
complete view of your customers so your
email marketing team may have fantastic
insights and your customers but it's not
sharing that with your search team and
you may not be getting feedback back
fast enough to your product developments
are your customer service teams so and
you may also be working with I know
there's a stat out there that on average
people use 13 different marketing
technologies but in fact we've actually
even somebody today told me that it
actually the different tools that
collect data that sit in silos numbers
and the thousands in their organization
how difficult it is to actually pull all
that data together so this is what
really interested me so when I start off
in clouds I did a global and round trip
just going and meeting as many CMOS and
c-suite CEOs and pretty much asking them
the same question which was how
satisfied are you with your own ability
to understand your own data on your own
customers and I always tell the joke
that I have a 100% record of people
saying they are very dissatisfied and
the joke is that there was actually one
CMO who told me that they were very
satisfied with the amount of data
mounted their value and insight they got
from their own data so that kind of
broke my hundred percent records and but
then afterwards they came back up to me
and said I only said that because I was
in front of my team and I didn't want to
embarrass them in fact we're really
unhappy with how much value we can get
out of our own customer data so what
that actually means is that the
statistic behind me were 13% of
organizations say they're making the
most of their available customer data is
exactly 13% more than I've met in actual
discussions with all of you and what I
find really interesting is that the most
the more sophisticated the enterprise
we work with gas the less satisfied they
become with unity value that they can
get out of their own data because it
feeds their requirement if they do start
seeing how fantastic insights they can
pull out of their own data then they
want to get more and more insights they
want to start using machine model
learning models they want to make it
they want to make it faster to get to
those insights they want to be able to
use smarter technologies and they want
to make it easier for all of the people
in their organizations to be able to get
to those insights quickly
so this is where cloud for marketing
comes in where we look like our overall
vision is to take what is typically for
a lot of people this linear model of the
data journey collecting your data
transforming it analyzing it visualizing
it and activating it and offering faster
simpler and smarter solutions for you to
create these delightful customer
experiences from your data and from your
marketing technology and ultimately with
the power of cloud computing to turn
that more linear model into a virtuous
circle because obviously as you activate
these campaigns as you activate these
delightful customer experiences then
customers react and supply more data
about what their preferences are what
they want from you and 63% of consumers
say they want brands to understand them
better and produce that the data from
their purchasing history to provide them
with a more personalized solution and
what we're here to do is to bring
technology to bear on that to enable you
to do that and more and more with your
customers so it's go into more detail
about how we're looking to turn that
vision into reality I'd like to welcome
like colleague Pierre and clarity up on
stage who is the global strategy lead
for Klara marketing thank you good
morning everyone
so I'm going to talk to you about three
things before bringing up three amazing
customers who are going to come and
share their experiences so the first
thing I'm going to cover is how you can
get started with us secondly why you
should work with us and thirdly going to
give you a bit of a product preview to
show how we're making some making that
process that you saw earlier from Damien
even more faster simpler and smarter so
the first thing that we've done and I
hope you of you were here with us last
year as well but we've developed a set
of solutions based on high value use
cases that we've heard in conversations
with enterprises over the past two years
these are eight use cases that are
packaged to be as turnkey and
high-impact as possible and each of the
use cases is designed to help you make
more of your data in service of both
long and short term goals whilst
minimizing the initial financial
investment required to implement and
also delivering you a fast time to
insight so we've got an email address
that you can contact the team on at the
end of the presentation and if you're
interested in getting a little bit more
detail on these solutions please please
do drop us a note and also make sure you
pop over to our booth down in the main
expo to speak more to the team the
second area that we've put a lot of work
into over the last 12 months in terms of
putting in things to help you succeed
have been around our partners so you
know that partners are an incredibly
important part of the overall cloud and
Google cloud ecosystem we've done a few
things there I'll just touch on a few
things so we have some we have 12 its
marketing analytics specialized service
partners available today and this list
is growing all the time in fact we'll be
launching this specialization more
formally during the course of this week
specializations as you know are awarded
to GCP partners with industry-leading
competencies and these partners are
there to help you from the various over
there from the very earliest point in
your journey - to Google cloud so those
are the folks on the left-hand side on
the right hand side you have a number of
data integration partners and these
broadly fall into three buckets the
first group the they're kind of ETL and
data partners through these through
these companies you can access over 300
connectors to data sources that you
really really really care about
and with these connectors you can be
sure that the data from the marketing
channels that you want and the sources
that you really care about is always
up-to-date and accessible in bigquery
the connectors themselves very quickly
scale to your needs
whilst promoting kind of agile workflows
that require less planning and fewer
resources to maintain the second group
there are the analytics partners so
working with our bi partners we've
created business dashboards with
pre-configured templates which provide
robust analytics to help you understand
and analyze your marketing data and the
third group our marketing technology
partners themselves so these are
companies that are inherently built on
GCP and can provide you with that kind
of SAS layer that you need or the
technology layer that you need to
actually make more use of any data that
you have already sitting on Google cloud
platform so we've put a lot of work into
these areas lots of the different
keynotes this week will touch on various
folks in these ecosystems as well
secondly I just want to touch on a
little bit why we're different this is
one of the first breakouts I hope that
you'll be attending today and through
the course of the week but just want to
touch on a few points here as you know
GCP is a leader in smart analytics
forests they're rated Google is the only
leader in their insights platforms as a
service report last year secondly we
have solutions designed to meet market
needs so we're going to touch on some of
those in a little bit like the use cases
we just walk through and the console
that I'll be showing you in a moment we
make it easier for marketers to deploy
workloads on Google cloud platform and
generate time to insight very very
quickly and of course we do a lot of
work and we are a leader in the machine
learning space with technology that is
truly different than any other in the
market we have over 7500 projects
powered by AI including Google's
consumer products from search through
YouTube through Maps secondly secondly
to the the differentiators in the
marketing analytics space I want to
touch on points that you may have heard
in the keynote earlier this morning
about why our cloud is different from
other clouds firstly security is at its
core Google
structure was born in the cloud and
built from the ground up with security
in mind secondly our fully managed
service offerings eliminate their
operational complexity that is required
when moving to cloud and making cloud
easy to adopt and thirdly openness is in
Google's DNA from our commitment to open
source software in areas like tensorflow
and kubernetes to the way in which we
build our products to give you
flexibility our open approach means that
you can develop applications that are
easy to run and faster deploy and
finally we're bringing you the best of
Google for your marketing needs Google
is inherently deeply entrenched in the
marketing space through all the work
that's done on the outside of our
business and we have integrations with
other Google products like the Google
marketing platform Google Ads maps play
and YouTube that help you get more from
these products and from Google cloud and
we've also looked to bring you the best
of Google for marketing bringing
technology developed at Google like the
vision API to help solve for marketing
use cases and Google has teams with
decades of experience working with
enterprises of every size in every
industry in in every nationality to help
solve your marketing challenges with our
technology so we've talked about how
we're helping enterprises today through
the use cases that we've packaged up
with the cloud kind of hexagons that are
available to everyone just want to give
you a a sneak peek into what we're
building to make that data journey that
you see on the screen right now even
faster simpler and smarter so the cloud
for marketing console is our first step
in helping customers solve marketing use
cases faster simpler and smarter on GCP
and it's in alpha now and available in
every region if you're interested to see
more than what i'm going to show you in
the next few slides please do head over
to our booth in the main hall to speak
to rpms and engineering teams so firstly
when a user opens the console their
dashboard will show the following things
templated queries links to templated
visualizations starting with data studio
predictive models that are available
at the click of a button and activation
points as well and I'll touch on these
these four things now very briefly
firstly we've made it faster to collect
data we've simplified the manual upload
process for getting data into bigquery
but by providing the tools and
step-by-step instructions you need
directly in the console allowing you to
get your data in faster secondly
managing all your marketing related data
is simpler with built-in tagging and
access controls we've created a
universal schema for web analytics which
allows customers to execute queries
against the same schema and combine data
from Google Analytics and Adobe from for
more comprehensive analysis and
reporting and you can maintain data
privacy and security by managing access
controls right down to the column level
for sensitive and PII data as well super
cool this is the last area the console
provides smarter insights about your
customers and products leveraging
templated queries and the same
predictive models that power Google's
other products no coding needed firstly
templated queries they answer common
ecommerce analytics questions and output
to a UI with the results secondly
customers can use our models to predict
lifetime value and forecast demand using
a simple UI again no coding required the
demand forecasting model is used in
Google products to forecast ad demand
and search trends and now we're making
that available to our customers through
the console and the last piece here are
the activation points so once you have
done your analysis and you've run some
predictive models you can of course get
a raw output of audience segments that
you can then use to push into any of the
marketing tools of your choice we also
have an integration with SendGrid
that allows you to push those lists
directly into that platform if you're
using it for email marketing purposes so
that's a little bit about the console
and a little bit about what we've been
up to to date and I hope you're excited
too about the opportunity to run your
marketing and
lytx on google cloud and the work that
we're doing in this area like I said
don't forget to come and see us in the
booth and today we're actually
incredibly lucky to be joined by leaders
from Ulta beauty American Eagle and
Colgate to come and share how Google
cloud helps them supercharge their
marketing data first up we have been
Pham senior architect and fart and Faris
Al Queda senior director data science
innovation from Alta beauty welcome on
stage guys hello everyone
so I'm Ferris this is Ben like I said
senior director of data science
innovation at Alta and we're happy to
share our story with you of what we're
currently building you know using Google
cloud platform just a little bit about
Alta beauty to give the context so we
are the largest us-based beauty retailer
with just over a thousand locations in
all 50 states now so something that you
know a lot of things differentiate Alta
beauty but one main thing that sticks
out to me you know in learning since
joining is that the beauty retail
landscape has traditionally been
segmented across price point and brand
so at Ulta Beauty we we we break that
segmentation we actually carry across
all price points and and 500 and across
500 brands so we care about 25,000 SKUs
also each other of our locations offers
a full salon service with skin brow and
hair services so it's it's really a very
different Beauty experience when a
customer walks in to alter Beauty than
what they're traditionally accustomed to
now this gives us great differentiation
it also presents its own challenges in
in marketing because we have such a
diverse you know guest profile so our
vision for what we're trying to achieve
in terms of marketing and customer
experience I think is no different than
what most retailers are trying to do
what we really want to do is enable
seamless and personalized experiences
across all touch points so
for a guest that walks into our salon
regularly and and and you know has a
stylist that knows her preferences and
can give her great tips we want her to
have that exact same experience if she
logs on to the alta app and so that's
that's quite a challenge when when we
you know with to today's marketing
landscape when we have all these
different disparate systems with
different data stuck in all those
channels but but that's our vision and
we furthermore we want to go beyond the
traditional marketing push mentality
where where we've traditionally used
these channels and marketing to mainly
push content and and push users to to
perform actions to purchase or to engage
with us we really want to make that more
of a two-way conversation with guests so
one to make them feel more engaged with
uLTA Beauty but also to collect valuable
data and to make their experience better
so from you know with this vision we
identified three main core capabilities
that we think are essential to enable
this vision so one we need the ability
to collect link and apply machine
learning to all this disparate data at
scale second we need the flexibility to
to take source systems in and out of
that data collection process without
disrupting to work the rest of the
workflow we also need the flexibility to
apply any to enable that intelligence
that we're garnering through our machine
learning to any of these channels so
that flexibility is key so we don't go
into the cycle of you know collect you
know in batch run run machine learning
and then and then market because in for
today's customer that might be too late
and that brings us to the third
capability that we really needed
real-time integrations so that if our
customers on the is on the site is on
mobile or has just transacted we
identify that immediately not two or
three days later and we can react to
them so with these you know by
identifying those three main
capabilities that were needed and for
our vision we're actually in the process
of building two
native platforms so one is
conversational Commerce and so a cloud
native you know through Google platform
the second is our personalization engine
that will enable these experiences and
so Ben is going to talk to us about the
first platform conversational commerce
in some use cases that were building
through that thanks various so as far as
mentioned our vision is to makes guess
every touchpoint
personalized and and relevant so we
built a compressive conversation
platform for our guests and this week
this platform will enable us to provide
two-way conversation with a guess across
these touch points and then on multiple
avenues and channels so these two demo
videos that we show here what we call it
Beauty bot and about your beauty
advisors which built on this platform
the one at the bottom is what we call
virtual Beauty visors which is helped
our guests to find their skin care needs
and that the final product for the skin
care needs and concerns and in this case
what you will appeal advisors provide
advice and guidance to find the right
products for their for their skin care
needs and and which go through the
conversation of AI and which recognize
the the daily skincare routine their
skin type based on that skin concerned
and then make the relevant offers and
recommendations and that beauty but on
the top is is that the guess they did
not receive their missing reward for
their purchase and they have a proceed
to prove their purchase
so this start you know interacting with
our Facebook Messenger and it initiate a
conversation without beauty bot and and
we start to we have we're not within our
platform we have an NLP engine that
predicts the intended message and in
this case it is the missing reward
points and in the beauty bar start to
engaging the gas asking them or looking
up their account get their details about
their transactions and then and then by
asking them to take a photo the Reese's
and then at their missing point today
points so now I'm gonna hand over to
Paris talk about the personalization
platform yep so so as we mentioned you
were building both these platforms you
know cloud native and both these
platforms rely on each other use each
other just as we describe you know our
vision is for to to enable intelligence
on any channel so conversational
Commerce is definitely one channel that
can scroll you know across social email
BOTS etc at the center of all that is
what we're building our to call our
personalization platform and to give
some context you know the in beauty
personalization is is essential the very
nature of beauty is is very personal to
guests it's also within this domain you
know beauty is not a necessity it's
something that's fun it's something that
are 30 million loyalty members are very
passionate about so it's become you know
clear and clear to us that engaging with
them and understanding our guests
preferences and being very targeted with
them is something that's essential so
the current state of our marketing but
also customer experience is pretty good
we have very rich data on our customers
like it had 30 million loyalty members
ninety-five percent of our revenue is
generated by those lords members so we
have a rich data set with with pretty
strong marketing capabilities in our
current state but I think like most
retailers we're trying to go beyond that
in future proof it so currently we're
very segment based very batch and
channel specific marketing where we want
to get to with our with our
personalization platform is to be to be
truly one-to-one to be real-time and go
beyond segments furthermore not be
reactive but be proactive and predictive
and so so how are we achieving that well
we're you know by by using Google cloud
platform to bring in all the data from
all the sources you know going beyond
transaction so if I guess transaction
with us it's almost too late to market
to them but going beyond transactions
and looking at all the signals may be
through conversational platform may be
through what they do
in our sites or other channels and then
feeding all that to real-time machine
learning and not batch base and and
enabling those capabilities to be shared
across every channel using a flexible
infrastructure and server space
architecture so Ben will actually show
some of what that looks like under the
hood so now we know what the
conversation and and personalization
platform are but how do we make it all
possible so we this is the the overview
of our architecture design that show how
do we leverage Google cloud platform to
make it all possible for us so first we
use the cloud identity and security to
manage users rows groups services
account in TCP and it go for us is to
maintain a privileged access model that
we want to make sure that every team's
every members every individuals are
assigned to the right access a public
access required for their job and also
we want to make sure that the Google
cloud TCP identity access management
roles and privilege are assigned to the
groups not individual and then we manage
these groups and group membership within
our outer Active Directory and we push
these groups to TCP via a Google cloud
directory sync so yeah first you can see
here the NHS in a store layer then this
is layers where we have both platforms
are running in on this layer on the
Google cloud compute engine listen it'll
live the real-time event from the
external systems such as the Facebook
messenger as the web hook as you seen
earlier in a beauty but video and then
that web hook is hosting on the cloud
network services sending the event
directly to the conversation platform
and on the left hand side we also see
alter system can send the data via data
stream or bash into our platform or via
the cloud pops up with in the comments
engine platform we have a interplay
component which is orchestrate or the
incoming and outgoing traffics in the
front
and also communicate with NLP NLP engine
for the message detent or intent message
for you know for example dear missing
the report points that we saw earlier
and then also interacting with what we
call it - kwazii running inside the
personalization engine is this is the
place where we have a complete 360 data
view about gas with real-time
intelligent models and then also to
bring the key role in the virtual beauty
advisor that we saw earlier so now we
have the data coming from the batch data
streaming real-time even real-time data
in the integration a flowing into that
interesting store how do we how do we
store all this data so the answer we use
the cloud storage what we specify as an
unstructured raw data and an important
thing is we want both platform be able
to use and read the data from the cloud
storage for our our continuous and
machine learning machine training
monitors training is twitching point for
us and now next layer we have the
process and transformation which we use
the cloud dataflow to process and enrich
the data into a bigquery as our
analytics data warehouse and also the
big table and and data store for our
in-house application use which is
sitting in the analyze in a slow layer
and lastly we also enable up dev ops
team to use a stack drivers contain a
registry for for login monitoring see
ICD pipeline for our platforms so now we
all know how you know tcp is playing the
key role for our in our marketing
platform enable us for to surround our
guests for every touchpoint but at the
same time we want to make sure it's
important point for us to apply our
infrastructures standards practices on
top of TCP for a long time so we here's
a few key highlights that we that we set
ours as our ccp foundation for example
backup recovery strategy we need to make
sure that we have the different the
regions owns disaster recovery we had to
build automation for scalability
we also need integrate DevOps our
standard tools for modeling and
operations governance strategy around
the technical support optimization
processes best practices and also
compute engine and storage our standards
for the OS patching licensing pattern
for the machine type and cloud storage
and security risk also important for us
for to manage to continue manager user
roles and groups and then lastly the
networking we make sure that we apply
the share PPC climates via VPN and DNS
and all of that thanks very much thank
you guys and next up we have Chris
Stevens who's the vice president of data
and Technology from American Eagle
Outfitters and I will not leave the I
will not take the clicker with me this
time they go Chris thank you very much
thank you very much I was just telling
my team I didn't know I was allowed to
have friends up here so all the work I'm
about to talk about I didn't do by the
way some people out here in the audience
raise your hand if you did the work
there we are already
so I'm Chris Stevens I work for American
Eagle Outfitters and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about what's it like to be a
customer you saw one to Google marketing
platforms focuses around customer
journey and understanding that journey
with your customer and we've spent a lot
of work partnering with our CX and UX
team to actually build out a really
comprehensive customer journey that I'm
gonna talk a little bit about and then
I'm gonna talk about the work that my
team is doing to measure and understand
that for each and every customer every
time okay so first American Eagle
Outfitters if you don't know who we are
we really are two primary brands
American Eagle Brand maker of the best
jeans in the world by the way the number
one women's jeans brand in America if
you didn't know that and also so and
also the women's brand
arrey so American Eagle is all about
sort of empowering youth and
individuality air is really about
celebrating real beauty in young women
so I say this pronoun
we in us because the reality is I'm a
vice president of something or other at
a four billion dollar company I didn't
do this work my team did all this work
okay so you heard a lot about you got to
understand who your customers are what
they want what are their intentions how
do you lis use machine learning and
technology and so on to make sure you're
there when they want you to be there and
I think for us it comes down to
listening right you got to be there
listening and engaging in a meaningful
conversation with your customer every
time when they're ready to engage in
that conversation so if you don't know
this Ramon song the next line is you got
to learn to listen or you're going to
get burned so I think for us it's really
about listening to our customer and
understanding who they are at the moment
when their signal and signaling intent
so this is a sort of Google eyes drede
presentation of a high level picture of
about ten people's five years worth of
work we have this really comprehensive
customer journey map that our team is
done that I can't share with you it's
terribly proprietary but you can
understand the idea is as a customer is
engaging with us they go through these
phases of engagement whether it's from
influences to consideration into
in-store Digital browsing purchasing
usage returns and so on and you know the
CX team like I said did all of us
incredible work mapping out the journey
doing ethnographic research talking to
customers understanding what it is like
to be that customer when they're
engaging with our brands and then you
see the little gray call-out box there
that's really the call-out then to the
technology team or my team in particular
in that our job is to understand and
measure what's happening for 20 million
people at a time as they move through
this customer journey so it's important
you know we're a business so we got to
tie this back to what we do as a
business right so we have sort of okay
ours and metrics in place that help us
measure this journey and understand
what's important so things like
conversion revenue per visitor average
order volume those are things that are
important to to online retailers all two
guys right I hope and then you know we
put metrics and goals in place so we
want to we want to move conversion by
two
percent let's say we want to increase
ever average order volume to $50 and so
on and those are sort of quantifiable
things that we can understand as we
measure customer interaction how they
shop what they buy what they browse and
so on but then the last part which can
be the hardest piece and I'm gonna talk
a little bit about what we're doing
there is how the customers feel about it
when they're interacting with us how
does it feel to be our customer not how
many of them are there what did they buy
what did they buy with this other stuff
and how can I make them buy more of that
stuff but how do they feel what did they
say right but not one at a time how did
they feel and what did they say
20 million at a time all the time every
time and how can I be there listening as
they're telling me those things so you
know two themes I'm going to talk about
one is personalization so similar to
what the Ulta guys said we have a pretty
comprehensive personalization program
underway we've got a lot of those
capabilities built out on the Google
cloud thanks to my awesome team again
but again you know we're not just doing
personalization for personalization and
quite frankly we're not even just doing
personalization to be there for the
customer when they want us to be and so
on we are running a business we want to
make sure we're doing personalization in
a way that ties back to the things that
our business cares about so calling out
for particular examples when we engage
customers in one-to-one experiences we
see significant revenue impact I think
the number there is 21% or something
like that of our customers that don't
interact with our personalization
tactics similarly on the conversion side
we see like Forex conversion over
customers that don't interact with
personalization so this might be a sales
pitch for personalization increased
units and outfitting right so we're
we're a fashion retailer we sell clothes
so we want to make sure customers are
outfitting themselves they're not just
coming for one particular item or
another but we want them to understand
the outfitting intention of our
merchants and so we see I forget there
it's 18 or 19 percent increase in the
units that customers are buying when
they're interacting with our
personalization tactics and then
similarly for higher revenue and margin
per sale right so the point is that the
team is doing amazing work and it's
having an impact and it's it's
technically interesting and in
I think to come to work every day and
work on this stuff then we can go talk
to the board of directors about the
impact we're having in forex conversion
and 28% or whatever it is increased in
average order volume those are
meaningful numbers for a board of a four
billion dollar public company so how do
we do that this is just a quick overview
again my team's here if you want to ask
them questions but you know we have the
problem that Damien talked about at the
beginning we got all this data it
doesn't natively exist in Google so on
the left your left right we got to get
all this data in there to personalize
people's experiences I got to have
customer data product data browse data
tf-idf is an awesome recommendation
based on text distance frequency for
items in our catalog in our assortment
you know and all this customer data in
there so that we can understand who's
looking for what what they might be
interested in adjacent to what they are
browsing at the time right so we put it
through this sort of pipeline on Google
apply some machine learning we have this
robust recommendation engine that we've
built and serve those out in real time
and a recommendation service that we
built that runs an app engine that our
site can call in real time I don't have
it a similar architecture but we also
have a real-time pricing and offer
service that we run similarly so our
customer can come to the site and based
on segmentation work that we do I could
make pricing and offer recommendations
or promotion recommendations to that
customer based on you know you can
imagine similar logic ok so voice of the
customer so this is about how does it
feel to be our customer and how do I
measure that right so a lot of this gets
back to sentiment analysis as you can
imagine but again we're trying to tie
this back to running a business so our
vision here is putting content about
what customers are saying and how
they're feeling about our products and
our experiences into the hands of the
people in our business that are
responsible for those things so you can
imagine our sourcing and manufacturing
team really care if our jeans are smelly
if they're bleeding if they're tearing
out at the seams if the fabric is
peeling those kinds of things
and you can get anecdotal one off here
and there customers said this customer
said that we got ten returns in the
distribution center because of this
thing but through the service that we're
building here we can put dashboards in
front of those teams and measure every
interaction that our customer has and
everything they say every time about how
they're feeling about every one of our
products so I think that's can be pretty
powerful for that team similarly for the
merchants teams right so the job if you
don't know the job of retail Merchants
is to figure out what clothes to put
together into an assortment how those
things ought to go to go together at
scale we sell like 60,000 different
units a year so that's a big problem to
solve and then anticipate what they
think people are going to like and then
try to read that through the season to
understand what people are feeling about
the products that they put out there in
their assortment and sometimes things
move faster and slower than they thought
you'd then sorry then they thought they
were going to and you know we can use
sentiment analysis or a voice of the
customer engine here to help them
understand not just this things moving
slow mark it down drive through the
inventory that's kind of retail 101 but
maybe things are moving slow because of
something else and people are saying
something about the product right and so
we ran an example last year where it was
around this time of year and our men's
shorts were sort of selling slow and the
merchants felt really good about the
assortment they put together but it was
just selling slow and in a traditional
retailer you'd think well okay it's
selling slow we got to move this
inventory market down get it out of here
take a hit on margin and suffer for that
right but through looking at our voice
of the customer we were able to see that
by and large customers were feeling
pretty good about the assortment right
they were saying positive things they
liked how the assortment looked - they
liked how the product felt right but it
just wasn't selling so we were able to
kind of hold the line with some
confidence to say no people like this
and it's not just hey do you like this
it's hey everybody 20 million of you at
the same time how do you feel about this
stuff do you like it and the customers
are saying yeah we kind of like this
stuff so we kind of were able to hold
the line in terms of markdowns and then
by the way that business came back and
it did great so it was just kind of one
other indicator to help us have some
confidence in the assortment they're
being put together okay
so similarly the pipeline again
to Damien's point at the very beginning
the problem is that I have all of this
data it doesn't natively exist on Google
right
I have product reviews I have purchased
surveys we have social media data we
have data from our call center we have
you know from the call center we have
chats we have calls we have emails
there's a lot of things that people are
saying right returns data there's
surveys on the returns you have to bring
all of that stuff together it
amalgamated into one thing so I can
understand with one taxonomy what are
people saying and how do they feel then
and that's where this kind of sentiment
analysis engine lays on top and then for
now we're kind of natively building in
tableau if there's a tableau person in
here a shout out kind of natively
building a little app interface into
blow so that our merchant teams and some
of the business folks that I talked
about can interact with that data okay I
wanted to talk about a voice of a real
customer you know arrey was the first
brand to not retouch to not airbrush our
models and we've kind of taken that one
step further in the past year and we've
actually recruited real women to be a
part of our marketing and advertising
campaigns and if you go to our website
and you want to see how we merchandise
our products on the website those are
all real women wearing our clothes and
so you can see in this particular
example I think there's a laser here so
this young woman was on our site and she
had had a heart transplant so she has
one of these big zipper scars down the
middle of her chest and we just so
happened to have another young woman in
a similar condition who was merchant
modeling some of our clothes on the
website and you can read for yourselves
but you can see that you know something
along the lines of she went to bed
feeling a little more comfortable with
herself that night based on you know
what we were doing so you know it's not
just machine learning and AI and
reasoning over people's intent to try to
sell them more stuff you know I think
the reality is that if you do it right
you're listening to your customers
you're paying attention to what they say
and how they feel and you can have a
real impact on people's lives
last up today we've got Tim Bowie who is
the global analytics lead and chief
infamy
security officer from Colgate Palmolive
Tim please come onstage
thank you great thanks for the
opportunity to tell the story of how at
Colgate we're using this technology to
really pull together a bunch of
different data sources empower our users
and and have a lot of fun for those of
you that don't know Colgate Palmolive if
we have over three and a half billion
customers for different product lines
home care pet care personal care and
oral care which is the majority of our
business very global country with a
majority of our sales outside the United
States very established in developing
countries and you can imagine that makes
a big challenge for us to understand
what's such a diverse group of customers
what they think about our products what
they want and how they respond to all of
our creative work that we're doing my
background before coming into to Colgate
was with the US government I had the
opportunity to run part of DARPA
smashing learning portfolio whether it
was fighting human trafficking networks
using AI to infiltrate terrorist
networks and and find radicalization or
trying to put put terrorists behind bars
before they could could act all that
required is going out and getting data
we didn't look for a tool that provided
that we found the smartest people we
could we build everything using open
source and we had all the computing
power that we wanted I also had hundreds
of people and millions a year to do it
when you're in a commercial construct
what's amazing to me is everything that
that I got mostly from organizations
like MIT that built everything in C and
what we're able to do entity extraction
and all this work you can get instantly
now on on Google's cloud and that's
incredibly exciting to me because we can
get a lot done very quickly in this case
we looked at consumer sentiment as a
starting point and it really opened the
door for us to do a lot of other
exciting things the first experiment we
did with Google is we looked at several
hundred thousand reviews of our
customers products online then wrote a
bunch of Python glue code to fit
together all the master data and add
some structure to the day
that was out there and then used
Google's natural language API and this
still floors me a little bit because I
had hundreds of people building
capability that got about half of what
this has and we were doing some some
really awesome stuff with it but here I
can use a smaller team cloud
infrastructure scale up what we need and
get a lot of work done but more more
quickly what's what's amazing about this
is entity extraction used to be one of
our hardest most technical problems it
comes out of the box along with
sentiment score salience of how relevant
and even magnitude of a feeling on
different topics that are there once we
can do entity extraction that's where it
gets really exciting because even when
we start with reviews depending on the
business user and there are eight
different business users that are now
using this data everything from supply
chain to e-commerce to product
development to marketing because it's
one big query data set a number of users
can do a lot of different things with it
and because we can rearrange blue
hexagons pretty quickly we can be agile
and respond to our business needs out of
that the first set of metrics we looked
at though we're looking at at consumer
sentiment across variety of brands and
topics doing the entity extraction from
that and then understanding both the
white space and end products but also
being able to respond quickly to the
different complaints or the different
feedback mechanisms when consumers were
providing to us one of the really cool
things we could do in one case we had a
user that had a team that spoke two
languages but needed to operate in ten
different countries was very easy to add
a natural language processing
translation API on top of that and then
quickly use that team to get their arms
around much bigger business really feel
like we're going to to fight in this
space with an army of capability that we
can quickly give our teams distributed
around the world we can also incorporate
new data sets very quickly so a source
like Twitter much more structured API
directly bring it in correlated to other
data sets that are there when I was in
the government we were doing really cool
things with tweets we could geo locate
based on text alone and at Colgate we're
finding a lot of great information
coming from the correlation of disparate
datasets
and the ability to bring data out of the
tools that we have into a common
construct and through using ml and
encode where we need to also using
tableau or the Google Data studio has
been the most helpful for for users that
don't have a coding background because
they've been able to rearrange and build
their own dashboards they don't get
stuck with a static dashboard that
presupposes the question and they have
the ability to really explore the the
data that they're working with just to
show the example architecture that we
used for this sentiment analysis you see
a common repetition of the Google Cloud
storage capability throughout that
that's because storing data raw is an
important lesson learned and in the past
and very relevant in this space as well
when we are going out and acquiring data
from a number of sources if we might
start on an e-commerce site ingest all
the reviews but we might then need to go
to something like a Kickstarter or an
Etsy to see where trends might be
starting and to follow them down to
their very source for that we need a lot
of flexibility to direct what I tell our
leadership is a spotlight to go essing
to go out and get us the data that we
need one of the most important things is
storage is cheap people are expensive
and time is critical with that in mind
we store everything raw because we have
to go back to the original source data
and extract extra information that we
can find there once it's there we use
cloud pub/sub also setting the stage for
streaming capabilities particularly
important in a supply chain environment
but here it allows for batch processing
for whenever reviews to arrive pub/sub
kicks off a cloud function that then
scores all the metrics produces all the
insight around the data pushes it back
into another cloud storage bucket and
eventually into bigquery the reason we
do this temporary storage along these
different stages is because it allows us
to store data raw which our data
scientists can go back then and extract
extra information from and then finally
once it's in bigquery from a CSO
security leader perspective it's very
helpful it's an append-only database I
can give my team's a lot of freedom and
by working closely with Google's
security teams I can distribute this
capability across the company really
quickly and do
knowing that the security is in a
construct that my sock is monitoring and
my teams can can use very quickly so
love to talk about the details of this
more I'd love to hear stories about how
others are using this capability to to
quickly move understand and act on all
the information that's out there and
thank you for your time
[Music]